Hãy đừng đáng bính gọt hai người khuôn chăm hai sống đang đến gần.
khi nhiều gia đình tất bật trình bị đón sôn,
thì tại quân càng buồn ba hài quân,
cánh buộc chiến sĩ tổ sấu hài tảm,
hai đổi bà một một lưỡng đoàn một sấu một,
đàn hình chiương hoàn tất công tác trình bị giềm buộc chực tết,
dài ngày trên biển.
Năm nay, tổ sấu hài tảm được dạo giềm buộc chực suyên tết,
với các anh, ló không chỉ là nhiều buộc,
mà còn là nhiều bình dự và chức giềm lớn là chức tổ quốc và yên dần.
Sau khi lưỡng đoàn,
những đặc là chức trên,
nằm nay tổ chức lượng chực trên biển.
Tổ sấu hài tảm,
và đặc biệt là thời gian chực.
Là sẽ chức qua tết người đánh,
bính gọt hai người khuôn chăm hai sấu.
Đối với đăng huy chữ lưỡng đoàn,
chúng tôi tả phải kìa thời.
Tö rào.
Chào con tàu và cho kìa trị hguy bị xin tàu.
Là mọng.
Bột trăm và trăm.
Cán bộ cho gió về như một.
Từa rồi.
Tưởng chính là h ‫ hẳng cắp trên biển.
Tất cả những biển bộ của yên thử dàn dài.
Tất cả những biển bộ có thể.
Hặc không chỉ nhìn quần biển về bơ chất.
Tình bị côn đặc biệt côn tâm là một tốt côn tác dục phương côn côn đổi,
Những cánh bộ chiến sĩ tham gia chực tiếp đều được tạo dục két dài quyết cung việt gia đình trước khi lên đường để ím tâm thực hiện những bộ.
Với bộ bệ cung tắc chừng bị chân tàu sống hai tâm vẫn giỏi rằng không khi sôn những cành đào kê quất được đưa lên tàu.
Một độ quý quần hỏi bánh chân, chừng bị giò thực phẩm cho những lệ tiếp xa nhà.
Những trị tham mới, xin người lệ chúc đến nhân dân cả nước và hầu vương ra đình.
Hàng ở nơi đất liên, lệ chúc chức quẻ hành phúc và vá sử nhiệm, chúng tôi xin thử hửa xe nếu cao tính thân tắc nhầm,
nóng két kỳ lọc, các phục mà có khăn ra khổ, và bảo vệ vương chắc nóc lập chụi quân của tổ quốc đến biển.
Hãy bỏ bỏ.
Trôn đang về trên khắp mọi miền đất nước, ngoài khuysa những người lính tàu sống hai tâm vẫn lăng thâm làm nghiệm bụt.
Sức bình in của biển trời hôm nay chính là mùa sôn trọn vẹn nhất đối với các anh những người lính hai quân nhân dân Việt Nam.